hey chess friends national master james
canty iii here with chess.com
and today we have the top five hikaru
nakamura king's indian defenses
very strong opening and he's a monster
with it so let's get right into it this
is the first one actually
it's going to be anatoly karpov versus
hikaru nakamura back in 2008.
so let's see what happened in this
position this was a samish this became a
samich king's indian defense that's an
early f3
actually in the uh in the opening and we
reached this position on move 22. now
after rick to d1
from anatoly karpov well you have to do
attacking chess kings indian is about
attacking as much as you can
dynamicism and fighting for win and
after rook to d1 there's knight to g4
not only opening up our bishop here
protecting the e5 pawn attacking h2 and
93 is very annoying
what a strong move and then after knight
g4 well karpov chooses bishop e2
and he says okay if you're going to take
this knight over here well first off
your rook's hanging
but actually this knight is definitely
trapped and it can't get out so
now we choose rick takes d1 from naca
here and then after bishop takes
d1 knight takes h2 again just runs into
the knight almost being trapped now of
course knight f1 is a way out of here
and you know white could probably hold
this game but he didn't choose this
instead he actually does rook takes d1
and after bishop takes d1 when you find
a good move you look for a better one
and hikaru finds knight to e3 not only
attacking the bishop
but attacking g2 and c4 all at the same
time
what a night right so 93 very very
strong and then a bishop to e2 from
karpov here
defending the pawn closest to the king
even though he can take on g2
which is exactly what he cargo does is
taking now on g2
and an f takes e5 and bishop takes e5
where black is now
up a pawn here in an end game h2 is
hanging maybe we can queen later if
we're able to capture this
but white needs some serious counter
play the pieces aren't the greatest this
bishop's hitting air in a way
this bishop's only defending and his
knight is on the rim which makes it very
dim so it's a very very hard a hard game
here for karpov
after bishop takes e4 he still plays on
and says okay you know what we need to
get some more pawns off the board so
after bishop g4 we're going to take on
e6
with a check here and hopefully we can
hold a draw here or maybe even more
because we do have two bishops as well
but we definitely need to play on after
bishop g4 you would think bishop takes
h2 and you can just take mine with check
as well
but actually there's a better move and
there's a move that he karu chose in
this game
what actually would you play in this
position
here it is guys instead of bishop takes
h2 hikaru says
bishop takes c4 for the score karpov
missed this one here
and after king takes c4 with the
intention is very clear knight e3 wow
this knight was doing
a lot of work today and 93 check
checking the king and attacking the
bishop on g4
after king to b5 there is knight takes
g4 and now
let's see the finish here now of course
black is up two pawns here
but maybe we can get one of them back so
let's see what happens king a6
and then hikaru chooses 93 instead just
to get a little bit closer and also keep
the knight centralized maybe just in
case these pawns get a little bit active
so after 93 there's king takes a a7 and
then knight to c4 so he's defending
because of course if we take on h2 he's
going to take on b6 and these pass pawns
are very scary
even though we have our own on the other
side of the board knight to c4 and
knight to g5 from karpov attacking the
e6 pawn saying hey
hey this is looking good i might be able
to really hold this and then after
knight to knight to g5 there's bishop
takes h2 and what do you do
there are past pawns ready to be pushed
here um from aaron nimsewicz as he says
in my system
past pawns must be pushed bishop takes
h2 knight takes e6 and
past pawns must be pushed and h5 and we
live and he's going to run these boys
down the board as quickly as possible
but we have pieces that can stop them
says karpov
so bishop to b4 maybe going back to e1
just to try to stop or get back as quick
as possible
also playing maybe a4 in some cases
bishop b4 and there's h4
then b3 attacking the knight and then
here it is
he says you know what i don't think you
can catch this i don't think you can
cast this pawn at all so he says
h3 take my knight if you like
and then here here's what happens knight
to g5 to hit the a6 pawn
and in this position guys the best
defense is offense
and that's that's going to be my my tip
for you guys and my hint the best
defense is often so what are you going
to do in this position hikaru nakamura
is playing black here
what do you do your pawn on h3 is
hanging and your knights hanging so what
would you do about this
well against the world champion uh
former world champion
and until the karpov he actually chose
this move here guys bishop b8
and we great oh my goodness wow that's a
check
that's a check and after he takes h2 and
what do you do
the game is over b takes c4 and queen
very very mean here from hikaru nakamura
it's very beautiful
and that was number one of the top five
kings indian offenses from ikaro
nakamura
now let's move on to number two and now
we move on
to number two of hikaru nakamura's
king's indian defenses the top
five now in this game it's alexander
believsky versus hikaru nakamura in
2009. now in this position looks wild
right
something you usually will see in the
king's indian defense now this one is
what they call more of the mardale plata
system
where a lot of times it's just about who
gets to who first we're going to push
all our kings here on or our
kings all our pawns here on the king
side we're going to try to use the rook
bring the bishop back and try to
decisively make this king as
fast and as quick as possible and on the
other side white's actually doing
everything that they can to tear open
the queen side
and when that happens it's a battle of
who gets to who first knight b5 was the
last move here attacking the rook here
now you would think you would just move
your rook right
especially if you want to use this maybe
to play rook f7 bishop f8 which is a
very common theme
and then rook g7 and trying to use the
rook as well
with this king side attack but
unfortunately it may be too slow
now what would you do in this position
well here it goes instead of moving the
rook here actually uh hikaru says
g3 i don't care take the rook i dare you
so bella bilievsky says i'm going to
take the rook
knight takes c7 show me what she got
here now after that uh knight uh knight
take c7 you would think you just take on
h2 right it's probably in the intention
playing g3 maybe take the knight after
taking on h2
but watch this guys now is there a
better move
maybe maybe not i want you to try to
figure that out what do you think
icarl played in this position
here it is guys instead of g takes h2 he
actually did
knight takes e4 for the score look at
this he sacrificed eight well first off
a rook
and now sacrificing a knight and saying
go i'm going for it
you will get made it or something's
gonna happen here now this looks
absolutely bananas
let's see what happens he says 96 here
i'm up a rook
and i want to trade pieces when you're
up material the rule is tray when you're
up not when you're down
so after 96 here i'm also blocking the
bishop because usually when you play h3
in these kind of positions we're going
to sacrifice the bishop and follow up
with queen h4 shut the door games over
but
a lot of times here 96 is a great
defensive move
and allowing bishop this bishop to be
eliminated actually so
bishop takes e6 d takes e6 and now
black's like cool i'm up material
you don't really have an attack here i
probably can just chill
over here on the on on the king side now
after uh
d takes e6 there is g takes h2 and if
king h1 it's gonna actually transpose
into exactly what happened here in the
game which was king takes h2
and then queen check and knight to g3 if
um actually
king h1 here is the same thing king
takes and then check
reaching the same position so he
actually just shows the take here
nakamura responds with queen to h4
and king to g3 king g1 and knight over
to g3 here
so this is not mate so you still have
work to do guys
you still have work to do sometimes you
may find a nice combination but you
still got work to do
i know there's a famous quote out there
that says the hardest game to win is a
game you're winning
you're a game that's already won and
that's true here you you should be
winning it's great the king
is like in a box here but there's no
mate yet there's no mate yet king f2
will be a fatal blunder
and that didn't happen so we need to
probably cover this diagonal as quickly
as possible and just in case e4 and
bishop d4 is definitely going to be some
of the next moves
so bishop takes c5 and says we live oh
yeah we got this
we have this diagonal one lock here
you're not getting to me
and he says well e4 anyway anyway
now here's the thing if pawn takes you
do have something like at the very least
at the very least you can take your rook
back and get some material and that's
the very least
and then knight takes as well you may
even have rook d8 in there in some cases
but this is made oh my goodness right
let's just get that off the screen this
is a family channel
so now after uh e4 here there's rook to
a4 saying hey don't take my rook i'm not
going to allow that
i'm up material we're also going to try
to x-ray this queen from the other side
of the board
you have to rick a4 uh hikaru stays
active in these type of positions guys
they move like a6 king h7 king h8
these will all be fatal errors because
you need to be fast
especially after you sacrifice material
you definitely need to be fast so rick
the ca we're now hitting the bishop here
and it allows him to take this bus this
pawn here on a7 and he does
and he says you know what hey look i
gotta keep my bishop on this diagonal
now guys
this is showing so much strength here
for mikaro nakamura there's a lot going
on
black to move what would you actually do
now probably a lot of you are probably
thinking e3
so let's just see take a second what
would you play in this position
black to play e3 is definitely a move
but it's not the best move and it also
runs in the knight takes e3 which is
like ouch right like how does this even
happen
now you're like losing losing so this
doesn't look good this doesn't look good
and here's a move that is
so strong here guys i didn't even
consider it and after i saw it i was
like
this is wonderful that's why carl was
half man half everything else now after
bishop takes a7 there's b5
and we live what a move here this was so
strong
so strong like b5 what does it do it's
forking oh al pasad of course especially
for the beginners here watching
on passant is in passing actually just
in french but what happens is i just
passed the b6 square
so you could amposantis which is great
absolutely opposant but then
oh my goodness bishop d4
check flex real hard get the man off the
board here oh my goodness what a move
what a move bishop d4 now blocking this
and then after queen takes knight takes
e2 mate and a queen oh my
this is i'm sorry we got to get this off
the screen we just can't allow that so
that didn't happen after b5 of course
after b5 same thing
even with knight to b6 is actually not
the same you can't check
so we can play e3 and now you can't take
this and how are you stopping mate
oh you're not right so let's go back a
little bit let's go back after b5
strong move here white is definitely
shaken up after that move
and then after b5 there's rook to b4
very very strong and hicaro says i have
nothing better to do we're going to take
this knight
now at least we're doing a little bit
better on material a little better
material and we have this decisive king
side attack that at a moment's notice
this is going to be over
bishop takes c4 threatening stuff like
e7 check and carl says okay
it's time to go for it we can't we can't
sit around i've done everything that i
can do now we're going to go queen h1
check king f2
and then e3 check first so the king is
is very very short on spaces if king e1
you have bishop c3 check which is gross
so he actually takes bishop takes c3
pawn takes and you have two ways to take
here
oh let's just take the knight well
knight knight queen h4 mate and we grade
that's a game there
beautiful so of course after f takes e3
there's king takes e3
knight takes f1 and bishop takes f1 and
then queen to g1 here sealing the deal
now believe resigned right here in this
position
but of course why did he resign well
after king e2 or king
e4 well first off your king is in the
middle of the street here
middle of the street just not looking
both ways this is definitely going to be
over very soon and of course one of the
there's two ways bishop h6 and rook c3
which can be done
on both moves king to e4 and king to e2
will both be met by rook to c3
and if you look at the material count
yeah of course this pawn is kind of
scary
and like you know there's a lot of
activity but your king is actually
unsafe it's not as safe as my king over
here and there's not enough threats and
black is actually up a piece here
what a beast move in a beast game from
ikaro nakamura
and that was number two now let's move
on to number three
and here we are with number three this
is boris gailfan
versus hikaru nakamura in 2010.
now here's the position here on the
board this is another
mardel plata that we've seen here or an
orthodox
modern system normal variation they'll
name it here on chess.com here but with
that being said guys this is more of a
mardel plata again
the the plans are very simple we're
going to attack on the king side as much
as possible again you see this rook on
the seventh rank
like we did in number two and uh also
the white's going to be doing everything
he can as you see all these pieces over
here
this looks kind of scary like it's all
about who gets to the king verse
and this is usually the theme in
opposite side castles
but in the king's indian it's like these
same side castles whoever gets to the
king first is going to win
and usually white does it by means of
actually destroying the queen side
and black does it by means of
checkmating the king this is why king's
indian is very fun
now after d6 here d6 was the last move
from gale fan here and he carl chooses a
takes b6
wild game here there's a lot going with
c takes uh or d takes c7 but then
there's queen takes d1 followed by the
bishop hanging
so there's so much to do now after a
takes b1 b6
actually um gale fan chooses bishop to
g1 he just says hey i'm gonna go a
little bit defense here we're still kind
of messing this up
and stuff's going to get kind of crazy
well you don't want to sit and do
everything on the queen side especially
in these kings indian type
battles where white's on the queen side
and blacks on the king side you still
have to attack so he says hey look
knight h4 we're going for it
like we have to do this now knight takes
a knight h4
and after knight h4 there's rook to e1
which is definitely a strange move
strange move here it was not the best
you actually had h takes g3
which was one of the best moves in the
line looks like this f takes g3 bishop
e3 and bishop h3 being very strong
with the intention of pawn takes in g2
with the check rook g1 and queen to
c8 and then bishop f1 and this is the
best defense
but black can still break through in
some short lines very very strange but
rook to e1 from gale fan here so after a
rookie one guys
now you have a lot of a lot of moves to
make in this position
what would you play
after rookie one hikaru looks up and
makes the faces that he usually does as
he's calculating and then he plays
knight takes g2
and says what do you do knight takes g2
is a big boy move from a big fellow like
himself
and after knight takes g2 there's d
takes c7 say okay hey you know what
we got to get the queens off yeah
nakamura is getting sharp
you don't want to be here let's just not
let this happen so in this position
again guys
what would you do here it is
after d takes c7 i mean probably trade
queens right
or not knight takes e1 is on the board
take my queen if you want to here you
know what get another queen
and then mate oh my goodness with a pawn
beautiful
absolutely beautiful nasty tactics here
that you see all the time in the king's
indian defense
now instead after he says you know what
i'm not going to get mated like that
that's embarrassing so queen takes e1
and then
hikaru does it anyway g2 check just
saying hey i'm going to activate my rook
now
king takes g2 and then rook g7 check
which is this
extremely strong move and then king h1
your queen's hanging
you should move it right or not bishop
h3 there's bait
there's may take my queen you can have
two queens if you like
and then after bishop a3 bishop f1 okay
cool we're going to defend the mate your
tricks are over now hikaru
please stop doing this yeah i see the
mate it's obvious says gale fan and
after bishop f1 guys black to move here
a lot of pieces hanging
h3 is hanging uh the b6 pawn is hanging
your queen is hanging
and he stops your mate what do you do
okay when you find a good movie look for
a better one we said that before you got
queen take c7
queen c8 maybe queen d7 right maybe
actually these might run into some
trouble some issues here but
uh here's the move guys queen d3 oh my
goodness
let me wipe my sweat off of my face
because i'm sweating after this move
queen to d3
wow look at this beautiful if you take
my queen well then that's just made and
we great very simple
and then after bishop okay well i'll
take the bishop then ah
same thing both ways oh my goodness
beautiful chess here so he plays queen
d3 hammering down on mates everywhere
can't take the queen i mean wow this is
absolutely
swashbuckling the greatest kings indian
type chest you will ever
see and after queen d3 there's knight
takes c5 saying okay we got to go for
something we got to do something here
and then he takes on f1 again leaving
the queen hanging i mean the queen was
hanging for how many moves guys like
this is amazing how many times can you
leave your queen hanging
and then voluntarily give it up and
still keep it on the board
and still be winning that's just never
happening now after bishop takes f1
there's queen takes f1
and black says instead of trading don't
really have any more moves
rick takes g1 is a error
fatal blunder so he takes on c3 and then
we do a quick piece count it looks like
black's up let's see a few more moves
rook c1 here
um because there's a lot going on this
knight is actually in trouble as well
too
but rick to c1 was played and then queen
takes e5
he says okay cool i'm going to queen you
take my knight and i take the rook here
and after queen e6
gelfand resigned
he resigns right here wow why did he
resign well let's check
let's actually just see he's just up a
piece now of course this is playable you
can
and probably should still play on but
after what just happened
your brain is probably fried he just hit
you with so many tactics bishop h3
knight takes g2
sack my queen for four moves and then
you know what we're done this game's
over right i understand from gale fan
here but with four pieces
versus three you know bad king structure
unsafe there's just not enough here and
he car was definitely going to finish
this one out
and after queen e6 gail fan resigns
beautiful beautiful chess here from
hikaru nakamura these kings indian
defenses
and now that was number three guys so
now let's move on to number four
all right guys and here we are with
number four this is vessel
off nakamura in 2017.
now the position here actually resulted
from a king's indian
defense the bayonet attack which is
actually one of the favorites from
kramnik here
and wrestling toppled off being a former
world champion playing the bayonet
attack is very strong here now we
reached this position with a lot of
counter play for black being uh
with the bishop here and uh stopping
rook f1 from happening
or you can't you can do it but we're
going to take it we also have an open f
file and queen c2 was the last move
played from topple off here attacking
the knight
so of course you do want to look for the
best defense being offense so you want
to look for offensive moves but if you
can't find any you're going to do like
icaru did and just move the knight
somewhere to still influence some of the
squares around the king
and where our pieces harmoniously are
placed right now
chapter knight to g5 their c takes d6
saying hey take the pawn if you like
go ahead a towel off because we need to
get this attack going and e4 did happen
now we're threatening to take the rook
here with the queen actually covering
the dark squares and there's no light
there's no dark square bishop for white
so actually this is a real threat we
actually will take this rook
usually this bishop is even stronger
than a rook but
if there's no dark square bishop from
your opponent to take over the dark
squares after you
depart from this bishop here or part
with his bishop what's going to happen
is um
black's going to be just fine after
taking this rook so after e4 there's
rook a
to d1 and then queen to f6 here
threatening queen f2 and mate
this is very very strong how do you even
stop this in a way knight f3 is looking
great too as well if bishop f1 knight f3
what happened right but all at the cost
of sacrificing a pawn or two
icaru has a very good strong position
here well rook f1 is like
the only move ouch i gotta give up the
exchange here
so after bishop takes bishop takes and
like whoa wait a second here we can't we
can just play knight f3 check right
but instead he actually chooses another
move here guys and you want to always
remember
that the more pieces you have in an
attack the better that attack is going
to be here
so we do have the queen the rook and the
knight that's three but we we usually
have like maybe two or three pieces kind
of helping defend the king
so we need more we need more ammo well
he says e3
whoa that's a strong move adding another
piece into the attack here
allowing queen f2 to happen even knight
of three sometimes e2
and if knight takes c3 well you're
hanging your knight here you don't want
to do that these knights are
discoordinated when it comes to
what's actually going on yeah they're
coordinated over here we got a pawn
and it's about the queen side attack but
where is your queen side attack
in fact black's just totally crushing in
this position
after e3 there's bishop to g2 and then
knight to f3 from icaru says hey i'm up
in exchange
why not here and he says you know what
i'm not going to just do this if i take
like this
this game is just over like why would i
go for this says topple off so he plays
king h1
just to keep pieces on the board and see
what happens hopefully we can survive
here
well keep the threats up you have to
play very strong chess
and when you have the initiative which
is time and activity you need to keep
moving
as much as possible and keep making
threats so knight to d4
attacking the queen here queen goes to
the back rank and you need to keep
making threats so this one's on you guys
black to move
here it is actually e2 another one e2
attacking the rook rookie e1 and then
kind of a threatened away
strong actually why not go into the
position queen f2 it's a great square to
put my queen on
knight to e4 says hey you got to get out
of here karu you can't stick around here
man like this is not that kind of party
and after 94 he plays queen f5
to now we can even trade queens
eventually here we can also put pressure
here
with a rook a to e8 at the right moment
because knight d6 is annoying
then we have d6 from topple off here but
that now takes away the knight square
they wanted to go to d6
so he plays rook aea thanks for the free
move he says and then 93 attacking the
queen
but look at the knights how they're
trying to defend with all their might
the queen the rook and the knights are
doing only one job
to defend the king because we can't do
anything else and then queen to d7 so we
back up a little bit here
h4 and king hey we still got a game says
topple off we still got a game here now
after king h8 there's queen to d3
really not attacking anything i don't
know if we're gonna take on e2 and now
we're down both the rooks
like that's just man we need to have one
at least right
and here's the move guys watch this cool
move here now black to move
what would you play in this position
guys a lot of moves a lot of moves to
make what would you do
it is actually carl says it's king's
indian you know
let's just take on e4 and think later
rook takes e4 big boy move from a big
fella and if bishop takes e4 does queen
h3
and queen takes g3 lights out lights out
gg start a new one so queen takes e4
that's a very strong move and you have
to in a way like
of course queen takes c4 and then after
queen takes d6 so he sacrificed the
exchange back but now we have the queen
hitting this
queen hitting this rook f1 is always
looming this is kind of annoying
we're only defending the knights
extremely strong everything's wrong with
white's position
after queen takes d2 there's a knight to
c2 says bro please
trade these knights and he does it he
says okay you know what i'm gonna do it
i'll trade the knights just for you
but then i'm gonna follow up with this
move right here which is queen takes
g3 and that's a wrap there guys after
queen takes g3
topolof resigns here um just due to
everything losing and
why is this wrong or why is he resigning
here after queen takes g3 the rook is
hanging
h4 is hanging let's say you do queen
take c2 or rook takes we'll look at both
if queen takes
obvious here take with check and you
need more pieces for a successful attack
usually it takes three
there are exceptions back ranked mates
queen bishop queen nightmates
queen rook mates by themselves but with
that being said it takes multiple pieces
so here's the move bishop d4
for the score and start a new game there
and the same thing will happen
after queen takes g3 and rook takes e2
taking king g1 and bishop d4 check
and another strong king's indian defense
from ikaru nakamura that was number four
guys hope you enjoyed it now let's move
on
to the final one number five and here we
are guys with number five this is
fabiano kirwana
versus hikaru nakamura in 2018.
now this position here this king's
indian resulted from an early h3 line
which the intention usually there is to
actually stop a lot of the king side
attacks
that you would get in king's indian
defense in favor of doing it yourself
with the white pieces doing an early
h3 and g4 maybe bishop e3s and queen d2s
and trying to actually mate black before
black is able to do any kind of king
side play now in these kind of
variations you actually go to the queen
side of the board as you see a lot of
queen side play from black
which is not the usual in the king's
indian defenses now here we do have uh
this h3 variation and it's black to move
here a lot of stuff going on double
rooks kings are both looking kind of
shaky here and after bishop e2 being the
last move because b5 was played
by hikaru so after uh bishop e2 there
was a king to f8 stepping out of the way
now after king f8 here well which is now
attacking rook takes g5 and if rook
takes we can just take with our rook
and if there's a check on the back rank
we just step back up g5 pawn is actually
hanging black has
exactly what we want here on the queen
side with decisive results if white's
not careful
so king f1 fabi says step out of the way
prophylaxis and also in a way we just
don't want him to take with check at
all so he carl says okay well you're
going to step out of the way i'm still
going to take the pawn
now i have these these pawns connected
g4 is going to be a very strong move so
bobby responds with f3
yikes ugly looking move here this bishop
is trapped now
in a way like there's nothing you can
really do so in fact
fabi's hoping for a blunder or even a
draw here due to black's pieces
just being better than white's pieces
and after f3 well you have to keep the
attack going and we're going to play b4
before fabi gets a chance to
so we're going to play b4 here and after
b4 there's knights of d1 stepping out of
the way
now you could play g4 here maybe some
other moves maybe trying to reroute the
queen
maybe trying to trade the light square
bishop but that probably wouldn't be
good due to his bishops being bad
now in this position what would you
actually play what would you choose
well here's what hikaru did he carl says
this is easy i do this i do my tactics
for breakfast lunch and dinner well here
it is
after knight to d1 knight takes b3
that's for me that's a strong one right
there thanks for the pawn
appreciate it knight takes b3 with the
intention of if you take well i'm
queening ouch
nothing you can do about that that's a
tough one character knight takes b3
well okay queen c2 from fabiano says i'm
not going to take that but it kind of
sucks because now i'm down the pawn
i don't have the king side attack i'm
looking for it's always going to be a
trade and you need multiple pieces for
an attack so if we trade this rook off
and the queen and
rook are discoordinated it's not going
to work your bit your pieces are too far
away
black's actually in a driver's seat
after queen c2 there's knight to d4
again always keep the attacks up as much
as possible the tempo or tempe plural
actually
well it's time you get to buy yourself
time you get free moves in a way so
after 94 attacking the queen queen has
to move allowing us to play
b3 past pawns must be pushed i'm either
going to take or play b2
and this is a wrap here your pieces are
on the wrong side of the board
nothing's going on this bishop's
terrible the knights on the back rank we
undeveloped our knight
so we developed it and then we
undeveloped it and it sat here on d1
here
and then after b3 there's a takes b3
from fabi and what do you think happened
guys very simple here
a2 and do what we do and that's a queen
there and that's very mean
this was awesome chess here i hope you
guys learned something today from the
king's indian defenses from ikaro
nakamura the top
five i'm national master james canty iii
here with chess.com
and i'll see you guys on the next video
[Music]
you